today on the anime zone a review of
Iquitos n' a compelling on me we're
fighting high school girls and martial
arts tournaments all complete with
plenty and plenty of
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh
expectations can be an very important
thing when coming into an anime animes
can become disappointing in your eyes if
you come in with too high an expectation
by the same time animes can become
better we keep your expectations low and
just expect the worse so with this in
mind I get my expectations of Vicky
totally lower than tigerwood keeps his
trousers when he's wife's not around and
I God tell you this show isn't that bad
now I'm just [ __ ] with you I bloody
hated it Niki Tyson is about seven high
schools at war with each other what all
students have become skilled fighters I
constantly battling to gain control over
the Kanto region since all teachers are
planning non-existent entities in these
schools enter sonsaku hakufu a Sinan
who's just recently moved to Japan who
challenges the top fighters in the
school and blah blah blah there's hot
girls and fighting and hot girls
fighting the anime supposed to be
loosely based on a very maps of the
three kingdoms and I do use the term
loosely since I personally thought lost
all historical credibility about the
time I'd looked over at the cover and I
saw that one of the girls battle attire
was a short skirt blue skimpy maid
outfit hakufu sonsaku's succeeded his
father of bondi sonken
but who cares about this ancient Chinese
history when you've got a bathtub with a
naked girl with some major boobie bombs
now that's entertainment
uh hold on did the narrator to take my
job okay anyone who's heard of this show
will probably expect me to be Tawna by
the excessive fanservice in this show
but there are a lot of legitimate
problems that need to be addressed so
I'll be beaten with a pony when is good
and ready to be beaten on wait a minute
I came out wrong
let's first talk about the main
characters sonsaku and token Suzuki was
a bob ago with very big assets but that
seems to be all she has because she is
dumb as [ __ ] and no that is not an
understatement some of the stuff he does
seems to be genetically designed to get
on my tits no pun intended I mean she
gets angry when some calls are stupid
then we find out she can't even [ __ ]
read and let's not forget Koken who
tries act like a hero because he keeps
babbling on about how he's given
protection Zaku but then he just gets
his ass handed to him every time he
tries to fight the rest of the cast is
pretty much forgettable would character
development being almost non-existent
and I don't think there was a single
character I liked with people being
annoying as [ __ ] with just being so dad
I couldn't care less about them though
this is quite understandable since
casters consist of a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a [ __ ]
a prostitute a pair breasts and a [ __ ]
animation also sucks for the studio
opting is just showing the final pose of
each blow then actually I don't know
animating the actual motion actually I
think some of the boobs
a better animated than the actual fights
for an anime filled with so many fights
you think they'd focus on making the
action because good as possible but you
know how it is sometimes you're given a
job to animate a fighting anime and you
blow your entire budget on researching
boob physics it happens now if in some
alternate universe you'd be curious to
watch the show and ask me which is
better
sub or dub I'd probably slap you in the
face for even considering watching this
but if you were to persist I'd probably
have to say sub it's not that it's good
or anything it's just that the dub is so
goddamn awful now I'm sure I can't get
through this review without mentioning
the infamous fanservice in this anime
and I can safely say that it just gets
to put on where it's bloody and Sol tink
so just to make my point clear about how
annoying it is I'm gonna be shutting
panty shot in the next paragraph at
approximately the same frequency appears
in the anime it really doesn't help
panty shot that all females in this
anime are forced to wear skirts with a
length of about a millimeter panty shot
meaning that every time that one screen
a gust of wind will most definitely blow
to reveal that underwear panty shot
fight Alice seems to be there for the
purpose of putting the girls in the most
erotic pose possible panty shot and all
girls wear clothing that seems to be
made out of a colored toilet paper which
will literally rip off if anyone so much
as sneezes on them panty shot add to
this the lesbian scenes panty shot the
nudity panty shot the rape scenes panty
shot and you have yourself an anime with
no [ __ ] morals panty shot you're
scared you and I are not at all alike
[Music]
[Applause]
your arms are now penetrating your body
doesn't it feel good this is an ecstasy
right
[Music]
see how annoying it is I think the
saddest thing about the shows when I
check for more info do you know what I
found there are three series of this
crap and there's a fourth one it's gonna
come out that's right for [ __ ] darling
seasons of this [ __ ] cry so you made
this popular enough to have four seasons
worth there's a majority of the anime
community now nothing more than a bunch
of lowlife hentai masturbating perverts
you only care about getting off at the
sight of animated goes exposing their
tits in the underwear no it's not and
shut up overall everything about this
anime is not only bad but degrading
without the fanservice it's just a bad
fighting and me with the fanservice it's
a bad fighting animate that has sunny
panty shots is actually insulting so
avoid this anime all cos unless you
really really desperate to see fighting
with tits or high school with tits or
martial arts tournaments with tits or
finally tits with tips and vagina I give
this anime a 2 out of 10 with tits panty
shot
[Music]